foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight on Piers Morgan uncensored with
me Isabelle oakshott and Richard Tice
virtue signaling Madness or a sensible
way to stop the NHS from reaching
meltdown we'll debate whether bringing
back masks is really Justified a new
year and yes a new boat Crossing already
Rishi sunak promises new laws to stop
the small boats but with Crossings
soaring by some 60 on the previous year
it is really actually a promise that he
will keep
and surgery obsessed we're going to meet
the hairdresser who's already spent 30
000 pounds and says he won't stop until
he he achieves what he sees as the
perfect body
live from London this is here's Morgan
uncensored with Richard Tice and
Isabelle Oak shot
and a very good evening well there's a
dark new threat to our way of life
tonight it's disguised as an innocent
looking piece of cloth not so long ago
we all had to carry these face masks do
you remember the fear of forgetting to
carry one finding yourself barred from
going into the shops or wherever
remember how hot and dirty and sweaty
they were they got loose they became uh
after you've used them a few times to
the point there was perfectly obvious
frankly they weren't stopping anything
they weren't stopping the spread of
germs but what about those nasty
disapproving looks from people the bossy
signs the announcements the pictures
absurdly painted on the ground
how often did you actually wish that
you'd invested in a business making
those face masks any color pretty
patterns funny logos but amazingly turns
out size didn't matter at all whether it
was fitted or unfitted it was one of
those rare items where actually one size
truly does fit all good god well they
really were awful weren't they and what
a relief when we were no longer forced
to wear them
do you remember how horrible it was in
particular seeing children being forced
to wear them at school
so what did you do with your masks have
you thrown them all away or have
uniquely kept them in a distinct pile
still dirty or perhaps you've washed
them ironed them and kept them as relics
for your grandchildren as a sort of
historic symbol of the Mad Mad time that
we went through well just when you
thought that Dreadful era couldn't go
any worse you put it all down to a
horrible mistake I'm afraid so the masks
are back
Yep they're back the ultimate virtue
signal Plus stirring your face with a
little bit of cloth that says you are
careful and considerate citizen putting
others ahead of your own face once again
we're seeing these boxes of them at the
entrances to public buildings once again
ministers are telling us that if we have
a sniffle it's sensible to put one on
and if you look around you on trains and
buses even on the street in the shops
they are I'm afraid definitely on the
rise now sure some people never actually
managed to let theirs go they became a
kind of weird little facial security
blanket but right now seemingly sensible
people who did stop wearing them when
the pandemic was over are putting them
back on again well what to do are you
going to dig yours out again and reuse
it are you going to object when you go
into the GP surgery in hospital and
someone asks you to mask up or will you
quietly comply anything for an easy life
well I think and I think you think so
too that people should resist this
Scourge they need to be brave and we
need to fight back until it goes away
forever we can be quite polite about it
all we need to do is point out that
there is not a shred of actual evidence
that these things make any difference
whatsoever now of course medical grade
Master a different matter that's the
kind worn by Hospital doctors and they
are effective but there is not a single
credible scientific study showing that
non-medical mass I.E the type that you
see on the streets make any significant
difference now by the way ministers know
this full well they just want to scare
people and to be seen to be doing
something I should know because having
written his book I know what Matt
Hancock the former Health secretary and
his advisors privately said a about the
utility of masks at the time and the
truth is that we know the messaging
around face masks it was mixed from the
very very beginning let's just have a
look now at what changed during the
pandemic
the evidence on face masks has always
been quite variable quite weak quite
difficult to know exactly and there's no
real trials on it and we will we've
undertaken a review we'll give our
advice to ministers and they'll make
decisions about what to do around that
on face masks we do we are Guided by the
science but in the government position
hasn't changed as of Monday the 15th of
June face coverings will become
mandatory on public transport
oh my that is actually giving me the
shudders me too well joining us now is
oncologist Professor Carol Sakura a
voice of reason on this issue as far as
I'm concerned and GP doctor Natalie Rao
thank you very much for joining us
um I want to start with you actually
Natalie
um and perhaps you can tell us whether
you are in your GP practice asking all
patients now to mask up well throughout
the pandemic I have worn a mask when I
see my patients I have not enforced
patients to wear masks in the last year
or so because there hasn't been as much
of a need and I think I've left it up to
patients to choose whether they want to
or not the concern now is that the NHS
is under significant amounts of pressure
you know that you can't deny the
statistics you've got patients not
making it to hospital bed shortages
staff shortages even oxygen shortages
but it's important to stress that
because
masks made any difference but they do
and that's that's damaging for you to
say that masks do not make it actually
looked all the we have looked at all the
studies well let me bring in uh Carol
Sakura here because he is an expert on
this and will tell us whether any of the
studies show something different I think
natural is more of an expert being a GP
than an oncologist but I think the
problem with masks is they're worn very
badly by people that often their nose is
showing that completely obligates the
whole thing the whole thing is negated
uh the other thing they get scrumpled up
in people's pockets the paper masks are
probably fairly useless and the examples
matter is brought here are decent mask
they're called
um filtering face pieces ffp and two and
three are the ones that we use in
hospitals and these are valid but the
stuff that you see on the trains and on
the tubes is not really doing much good
to anybody so what do you say to that
well I do agree that masks need to be
fitted correctly there isn't any point
wearing one if it's going to be hanging
below your nose or on your chin and we
have seen many people wearing them so
okay if you're one of those people then
it's not going to work but a well-fitted
good quality mask like an ffp2 does
reduce transmission of both aerosol and
droplets so I know there's been some
debate about well does it help with
aerosols if you've got a cloth mask
which has bigger gaps in it so that
things can pass through perhaps not but
these ones certainly do and certainly
with droplets even a well-fitted cloth
mask will help but the biggest I think
most reputable study that was done in
2020 in Denmark called the Denmark 19
study of about 6 000 people that showed
that actually there was no statistical
significant difference between those who
wore masks and those who did not wear
masks and the professor of
evidence-based medicine at the
University of Oxford Carl Hennigan he
was very clear he wrote about this at
the time and he wrote about it yesterday
again I think the problem is that there
are 28 star is most of them are
completely useless they're sort of
almost anecdotal this was collected by
Health security British Health Security
Agency in 2021 and there are two that
look good one is that the study you just
mentioned and there's another study
which showed the opposite that the masks
were effective so I think the jury is
out what I really object to is this idea
that if you wear a mask you're somehow
saving the NHS it's just like you've got
cancer don't bother which is exactly
what you're suggest I mean I'm sorry
you're not saying you we're saved no I'm
not suggesting that we're saving it but
it was a small step it's an easy step I
mean you're just saying how inconvenient
it is just another little thing it's
just like all those things incrementally
built up during the pandemic is it more
inconvenient than it's not about
inconsistency I actually think that it's
something there's something very
Sinister about covering your face with
something which we all know doesn't work
what can you say that when several
countries and cultures have done that
pre-pandemic for years but let's look at
the evidence of Germany where actually
they were required to wear the ffp3
marks for the whole of 2021 and guess
what happened at the end of 2020 they
had a huge huge surge of the new variant
so essentially it made no difference
whatsoever and I think
just look at the evidence the scientific
evidence the anecdotal evidence and I
think it's it's clear particularly when
most people are wearing pretty grubby
dirty cloth masks but we're not asking
everyone to wear an ffp3 the advice is
that if you're unwell and you have a
cough or you have got a runny nose then
wear one wear one if you're going into a
healthcare institution where you're
going to come into contact with more
vulnerable people who are more
susceptible to these viruses so we're
not going to have sort of a complete
closure of all these viruses but you're
going to restrict it enough so that it
buys the NHS a little bit more so are
you actually saying that and instead of
the advice being please wear a mask
actually the advice should be changed to
in these settings in these circumstances
please wear a medical grade mask yes I
think right I think that's sensible and
that I think we could probably
well you know I'm not gonna love it but
I could see the case for that can I just
ask you how you felt about children
being forced to wear masks in schools
I don't think anyone should be forced to
do anything I think at the time when we
weren't fully vaccinated and we wanted
to keep our children in education
wearing a mask was a sensible option
that like I said is not restrictive it's
safe it's not harmful and it's easy to
do so of course there are certain
children for example with learning
disabilities autism Down syndrome that
that they shouldn't have had to wear a
mask and they were actually exempt from
wearing masks but for the majority of
children who are happy to wear them I
don't think any kids are happy
to wear them I said how are you coming
here because I can see you burning
burning I was amazed the leader
editorial in the times today talks about
Mars and it's very it's very much as you
say Natalie but at the end it says if
you feel iffy you should wear a mask now
wait a minute if you feel iffy if you've
got a temperature if you're ill surely
you shouldn't be going into a crowded
room with other people right and the
trouble is you know I came on a very
early bus because of the train strike
this morning and you know the people's
sitting there on a 6 30 bus where I live
can't afford not to go to work whether
they've got fevers or not they won't be
paid and maybe the times readers aren't
in that category but there weren't too
many copies on we need to come back to
this point about children because I
fundamentally disagree I think all of
the evidence shows that actually
children's education was dramatically
hindered in terms of their development
particularly for younger children but
not either wearing no by the wearing of
masks which held them back teachers
couldn't properly communicate and they
felt terrified they'll fail to afraid
particularly young children who
literally for the first couple of years
of their lives they weren't seeing other
faces and I think the evidence shows
that actually it held back uh children's
natural development in particular speech
development for younger children
especially if those from deprived
backgrounds as well there was a greater
deprivation difference between the
wealth I mean how do you deprive when
you saw babies
being made to wear masks I hadn't seen a
baby being made oh I have you know well
I see babies in my practice and no baby
was on okay so so at what point do you
think it's acceptable for children to be
asked to wear masks if they're school
going and happy to wear one then it's
fine but let's just keep coming back to
this happy to wear white it's not normal
or natural or in any way kind of
acceptable thing to do when most
children can cover up to wear them at
the moment
this is the thin end of the wedge isn't
it at the moment it's just in certain
places sometimes and then a month down
the track another Minister will say just
a little bit more Nicholas sturgeon will
get involved oh yes and everyone's
terrified of her do you think anyone
thought that children would have to live
through a pandemic did you think you'd
have to live through a pandemic these
are unprecedented times no one expected
this to happen but you don't you don't
impose things on children without
evidence that it's not going to harm
children's development and it's not
going to actually harm their health and
the clear evidence that we've learned
since masks were worn by children for
way way too long is that actually it has
been harmful
no one is asking all children to wear
masks they wouldn't ask any children to
wear a mask if they're happy to do so
then and they are unwell and going out
somewhere then do you have children
I don't I don't but I am a GP so I see
children day I mean I have three
children not one of them was happy to
wear a mask no normal child is happy to
wear a mask children just want to be
children in a free environment they
don't want bits of cloth stuck to their
face and be made to fear a virus that
wasn't even a significant risk to all
but the tiniest minority do they like
wearing fancy dress costumes with masks
saying that they're Captain America they
do yeah
this is how I did my work how do you
think I examine a child no one likes to
be a dress for one evening is one thing
you know making them wear it every day
I'm pretty sure my kids would be
objecting no one is asking a child to
wear a mask every day I don't know why
we're talking about this we're talking
about it because because it harms
children's development and education
through this period Carol just like it
doesn't have them yeah General you're
ganging up of this I'm naturally I'm
afraid I have to say something I don't
think it will happen because of what
we're doing tonight and other people do
doing the same thing if we make most
mandations
our God is up that's why we're talking
about but maybe it's a test to see what
would happen if you suggest people all
wear masks or if you suggest mandatory
mask weight yeah
Carol Natalie thank you so much
fascinating debate we will come back to
it we will try and stop it next tonight
so the first migrant Crossings of 2023
has already been brought to shore
Yesterday by UK's border force with 44
migrants being brought to Dover but the
Prime Minister yes he's pledged it he's
promised it new laws again and but will
they work debating that up next
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
coming up or he spent more than 30
000 pounds so far when will he stop
we're going to meet the man who is
obsessed with plastic surgery but
but before anything else we just need to
reflect on that discussion about masks I
mean Natalie what was she talking about
the sort of fantasy dress and linking
that to Mars so I thought she was she
was doing quite well because obviously
we're both quite hostile to her point of
view
um I was sort of buying into the idea of
medical grade masks being effective in
certain settings but she totally lost it
to me when she started talking about
children being happy to wear moss and
she just keep using that expression
didn't she and I just kept thinking of
my own children thinking of course
they're not happy to wear masks and nor
is any child normally happy but then she
started talking about this fancy dress
analogy oh are they happy to wear a
fancy dress well yes and it's only for
one evening I think she actually
admitted that it didn't help children's
education and essentially harmed it I
think that was a key Point yes I mean
Carol Sakura provided quite a good bit
of balance there didn't he but I mean I
wasn't left feeling any less militant on
this issue this is the thin end of the
wedge and I am seriously worried yeah no
no definitely and and it's just the
creeping nature of it isn't it yeah
absolutely
but first well the Prime Minister Rishi
sunak he's promised once again to pass
new laws more laws to stop the illegal
migrants crossing the channel this is
one of the government's five key
priorities Yes again more priorities yes
the scale of the small boats crisis has
soared over recent years
so in 2020 just over 8 000 migrants made
the crossing which is actually a huge
number but that shot up to more than 25
000 the next year turns out that was
just the tip of the iceberg and a record
of 45
756 made the journey last year and with
44 migrants being brought ashore on the
first small boat crossing of the year
the question is how many more are going
to succeed in reaching the UK this year
well uh joining us is the former
security and Border management expert
we're not a former expert are you you're
a very current expert Henry Bolton and
immigration lawyer hard Jackson bangle
thank you very much for coming on to
talk about this issue so very soon act
today pledged to introduce bring in new
legislation to stop the small boats
slight feeling of deja vu I have slight
say
um what do you think is going to change
this year I don't think much is going to
change unless we're going to address
fundamentally the root of the problem
and that is the ganks who are profiting
and putting people on the dinghies and
on the boats there's been no sort of
announcement as to how to get them and
so we know that people trafficking makes
more money than drug trafficking so it's
a big business you now you don't stop
drug dealing by locking up or punishing
drug users in the same way that if you
start detaining or putting
Asylum Seekers into detention or pushing
them back hoping that this will stop the
people's Smugglers to whom one boat is
worth 250 000 pounds it is a lot of
money so do you actually work then as a
as a lawyer do you work helping the
cases of some of the people that are
coming over on these books
um I used to a lot you know what happens
is they're dealt with at the point when
that where they're actually coming they
don't have a lawyer there right they
only need a lawyer once a claims being
processed or if the claim is refused and
so that they don't really get legal aid
for that anymore uh in relation to that
so if someone's claim gets refused then
when they have a right of appeal we can
ask for a review on that or if we feel a
decision is unfair it can be challenged
or if if it comes to we think that human
rights been obstructed or anything do
you know ethical problem with making
money you know it's what you do for a
living off the back of giving advice to
people who have quite clearly come here
illegally and illegitimately yeah but
it's not actually illegal to come here
and it's not illegal to claim Asylum and
there's no there is no but there is no
obligation on anyone to claim asylum in
the first place they land however
it's their claim it is an obligation for
this country to listen to their claim
and deal with it fairly whether they
accept it or refuse it but actually it
they have come here illegally they've
come here without papers and that is
quite clear under the uh under the UN 51
convention they've come here illegally
so because there's no legal route for
them to come in
okay we don't have a legal obligation to
provide roots to the rest of the
billions of people around the world to
come and live in the United Kingdom um
Henry let's let's ask you so uh hijab
doesn't think that much is going to
change the beginning of last year uh the
the Tory government said that the
nationality and borders bill would
change everything that's now been
enacted yeah and it's changed nothing
correct and I don't see this as changing
anything I think what we saw I mean in
general in terms of Rishi sunax Five
Points is five promises was a
firefighting response to what he sees as
a threat to the conservative party in
their election in a couple of years uh
or the next general election and he's
right to see that as a threat um but
he's got no answers there is nothing new
in anything he said and particularly on
the immigration side uh another piece of
legislation all that's all he's saying
saying to us is that the legislation
that we put before Parliament before
simply wasn't up to the job
the reality is there's so much money in
the gangs and by the way the vested
interests here in the UK frankly are
making a lot more money a lot more
profits than the gangs but until until
the truth is until we actually pick up
and safely take people back to France
nothing will change well there's there's
a couple of elements to this Richard if
we're going to be successful
um the government talks about breaking
the business model to do that we have to
sort of think of this we take the
analogy of of travel agents and they're
marketing their holiday destinations
this is what the people Smugglers are
doing and Albania is a classic case and
the cost of our albanians and and people
like that classic case and it's a very
good example because it demonstrates
very clearly that we've got people
coming here claiming Asylum to
effectively bypass the rules
um who are economic migrants they're
there's very clear case and that's why
the Albanian thing is so important not
just because of the numbers but if you
want to disrupt that you have to break
that business model and the only way to
do it is to go after as hardship says
the organized crime networks you've got
to disrupt them and you've got to hunt
them down ruthlessly not just work with
a bit of training and capacity that's
one element though yeah the other
element as you would do if you want to
reduce the number of tourists go into a
country is to reduce the attractiveness
of that country the acceptability of it
and we are an incredibly attractive
we're very attractive and all you have
to do is look at the amount of Asylum
claims that we accept and that we
process and we grant for nationalities
compared to the European Union for
example the French or the Germans and so
on who absolutely take a great deal of
particularly again in the case of
economic migrants they they understand
the difference between an economic
migrant and a refugee and France for
example only grants two percent Asylum
claims to albanians so we we've got a
massive discrepancy do you understand
the difference between an economic
migrant and a genuine Asylum seeker of
course right and do you accept that the
overwhelming evidence from the
government itself is a very significant
proportion of those coming over on these
votes are actually opportunists once
again that's because there's no way for
low-skilled migrants to come to this
country
there is an extraordinary number of ways
to come to the work the work permit
scheme and it's called a tier two skills
right so it's called a skilled worker
there's nothing called an unskilled
worker if I'm a waitress if I'm a lorry
driver I can't come into this country
yeah
but you can't you've got to come that we
don't want them but the government
wanted them we would create that
facility the thing is where it doesn't
exist where we say actually we don't
want the low-skilled workers that's
government policy it's in our Sovereign
right to enact that policy and not
provide a routine for that so albanians
again I use that is because they're a
great economic example of economic
migrants they can apply like anybody
else for a work permit
can they all get rejected Henry a work
permit can only be sponsored yeah
they're right there will be rejected
because because certain categories so
like a waiter a security guard
all right it's not you you're such a
skilled working scheme there are 800
different job titles down to a salary
it's just over 16 000. a waitress not
not it seems just hairdressed Leicester
why should we take them we don't need
that I'll give you an example right an
example is as soon as you enter this
building yes you see two security guards
yes who are migrants
they could not they they came under
probably under free movement or when the
Visa system is available if they want to
come over now they can't do it your
makeup artist who did my makeup she's a
mind we've got five million people out
of work benefits we want to get our own
people back into work
if that's what you believe the answer
then is to argue in terms of politics
that we need to create that yeah but it
is not
absolutely it is not to turn around and
say well because the government policy
is such that we are not accepting such
applications from abroad they are we
should accept the the fact that they
come across on small boats that's
unacceptable it's great it's it's it's
there's no defense of breaking the law
no one's saying that we should accept
um Asylum Seekers under or economic
arguments under the guise of Asylum
Seekers what we're saying is we should
understand there is a need for migration
across the whole Board
of people no of course we don't so what
limit do you would you put on it
why don't you answer businesses
when it asks the care sector what they
need I want to answer tracking
Industries what they need why are we
hurting our own businesses and make and
having shortages because like I'll tell
you why because I want to get our own
five million people
right you both agreed nothing's going to
change correct what hardjap is your 4
cast for the number of elite people who
will come here illegally over the
channel it won't change so you're saying
at least another I I it won't change
because the gaps to stop the gangs your
forecast I I Richard if you look if
you'll forgive me I'm going to look a
bit slow
what's your number further than the year
I think in five years we're going to be
facing the situation that the the
Americans have got on the south border
Southern give me a number Henry by then
no now this year 2023. come on go on
take 40.
60 to 100 000. that is a pretty wide
range Henry it is
nothing is going to change I wish you
soon out you better listen in coming up
next well back to the Prime Minister
again he wants all Futures at the time
of Crisis to study maths until the age
of 18. does the current country really
need this we'll put a maths test
designed for a 13 year old to our panel
to see how they get on
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
still to come tonight we'll meet the man
who has spent a year's salary trying to
make himself look perfect or at least
what he thinks is perfect but first
let's just recap on that debate over the
migrant the migrant Crossings and sunax
pledged to bring in new laws to stop it
happening I mean what was interesting is
that neither of them actually thought
they were going to make any difference
it's absolutely ridiculous here we are
another year another bunch of laws from
another Tory government with another
Tory prime minister that talks the talk
and never delivers on anything and they
both agree Nothing's Gonna Change
Henry's prediction 60 to 100 000 even
harder money he's got a vested interest
he does have a best is interesting the
other thing is it always seems to get
kind of conflated with The Debaters to
what how much migration we need at all
whereas actually how people are coming
across as a sort of a separate issue
isn't it well we could go on about that
we could go on about that one of my
favorite topics but some of my favorite
panel of course delighted to be joined
by TV contributor Esther kraku and the
Daily Mirror associate editor Kevin
McGuire very warm welcome to you we are
going to put you straight on your toes
team because yes the Prime Minister
wants us all to learn maths so just a
quick question for you here we go oh
dear God
so Esther listen up what could go wrong
an example all right this so mayor
bought 18 apples
she used 50 of the apples to make apple
pie
and mixed a third of the apples with
other fruits to make the salad how many
apples did she have left instead of the
remaining apples you're so right
absolutely nailed it you see we've
identified the floor the grayness and
the wording okay so it's a third of the
total apples
there you are look at this absolutely
well done no I am I am impressed I hate
these questions so I've got kids that
age and they sometimes do show me their
maths Homer and ask for help and I'm so
embarrassed to say yeah I think you have
to be a bit of a linguist as well
exactly yeah and the wording is often so
badly done it could be mainly could I
suggest if she's not gonna do this for
16 17 18 year olds he doesn't do apple
pies but we use paints and shots
let's come on to the Prime Minister
because the reality is that he's given a
speech today that he rushed forward
because I gave a speech in the morning
is all about me come on it's all about
me nothing changes here it does it it's
all about you it always is steady
um but look um he's given five key
priorities and we keep hearing about
priorities but um Kevin what are your
thoughts about this I mean the big
headline the briefed out maths to 18
really which isn't one of his five
priorities because three are on the uh
the economy one's on NHS waiting lists
and the fifth is on boat Crossing which
proved it was rushed so of course it was
and it Richard with all due respect you
I think it's because Kia storm is making
us be sure
if you haven't got anything really big
to say don't say anything and uh that
was the problem because he came with
five rather vagues
[Music]
um
how likelihood do you think of him
achieving them so if we just quickly run
through them there was reducing
inflation by half which is which was the
only specificity that'll hit this year
because all of the office for Budget
responsibility is saying it'll be 3.8 at
the end of the year economy well from a
pretty low State Bank of England says
there's going to be a recession this
year so that'll be 2024 not this year
he's banking on the uh the Americans not
teaching technically into a reception
you can remember the other one reducing
NHS waiting lists well they could fiddle
that that was the Vegas of them all
because he just said produced he didn't
actually say by how much probably 2024
to uh um more jobs wasn't it with more
and better paid jobs or unemployments
forecast to go up half a million and
then the Boat Crossings in a way you
can't cross him because even if you have
a safe and legal route in which I think
we should have you may disagree but I
think we should we've already got one
it's called the skill workers they would
still be those who wouldn't be allowed
in who are gonna take a chance which is
a backhanded compliment I think I think
he's doing that on the on the chance
that there's better negotiation sort of
cooperation with the bought the Border
force in France I think that's why he's
saying that because he's sure that will
pan out
um on the mat point though I do I do
think it was I understood what he was
saying I think I might be the only
person that kind of understood his
trajectory but he didn't elaborate it
very well where's where's the sense that
actually the country is in crisis the
country is literally broken nothing
works in this place anymore that has no
sense of urgency about any of these
priorities no because it's on it's on
their watches exactly they've been in
power 13 years so do you really want to
say we did have the biggest call we did
have the biggest fall in in living
standards last year on record we have
got a wave of strikes and HSS in crisis
all have happened on their watch so he
can't say the country's broke he just
can't do it he's got pretend things are
a bit better than they are and he will
make them even better one person that's
not pretending things are better than
they than they should be is Nadine Doris
you know the Boris Johnson's outrider
she issued a furious tweet after that
Announcement by Rishi sunat basically
talking about the unraveling of the last
three years of progressive what's he
called Progressive Tory government what
did you make Kevin of that intervention
by Nadine Doris and it will of course
fuel speculation about a possible Boris
comeback well it will because she she's
his outright only she's that she's the
number one fan girl he put her in there
we get a woman that loves you like this
yeah
but most people will have to get a
labrador to get that amount of a divorce
but of course she's also she's off to
put it lightly because they're not going
to privatize Channel 4 by the looks of
it which she said they should and he
sees it not as a priority and there's no
real case to do it anyway
red herring eggs given everything else
that was going on and I think it's a bit
insulting actually to the British public
with all the things going on you really
want to sort of play political Tetris
with this pointless privatization scheme
I don't think I I just think it would
show the priorities off and it'll really
not because Isabel but you know you know
there's going to be push Johnson forward
all the time and sunac isn't isn't
secure as Prime he isn't secure so I
think the over I'd be really interested
in your take on you know sunax been
there for a few months now the
overwhelming sense seems to be both
within the party and among voters that
he's just incredibly underwhelming yeah
well I'd agree but I think he's probably
the best they've got and when you on
your third prime minister in a single
Parliament I don't think you can change
again dismal reflection on 350 Tory MPS
he's the best they got I describe him as
a bureaucratic boring bean counter but
the thing is he has to be only slightly
better than than kirstama who is also a
bureaucratic foreign
it's about your opposition not about you
being a standout character and this is
this is the point I think if you look at
if you look at kistama and Rishi sunak
right now their politics aren't actually
very different a lot of the very they
are pretty big
they're both variants of socialism
and I think but you can see that because
all the more left-wing part of the labor
party are very unhappy with Kirsten at
the moment as well so you can see that
there's really not that that different
in terms of their actual the actual
policies I think if if Kirsten was to
win the general election tomorrow his
his sort of political Outlook would be
just slightly more woke versions of
Rishi sunath but the actual substance of
it wouldn't be very different because
ideological politics is dead I think you
know look tsuna is a thatcherife that's
what it is but he hasn't he hasn't been
able to deliver I see and he has the air
of a provincial Building Society manager
you can imagine I'm in a very small
branch and a little town you're giving
Italian biscuits and saying you can't
have your mortgage that's what yeah
that's that's what he's about he's just
he doesn't Inspire I think we're going
to disagree with you on that well look
before we let you go
segment on the program is an
extraordinary story about a young man
who has spent over 30 grand on surgery
trying to create the perfect body we
have to watch did he succeed would
either of you go down that route
potentially at any point what makes you
think I haven't and it went wrong come
on Kevin no no no no look people don't
spend their money as their wish but no
way no I'm not against it to be honest I
wouldn't spend that much and I I just
you know I don't think anyone needs that
much but I'm not against cosmetic
surgery and I I'm just I'm not gonna lie
I don't like asthmatic surgery on men
I'm just I'm not here for it so I don't
find it attractive oh okay so you're
drawing a distinction between men and
women oh yeah oh yeah because it also
men can't tell the difference when a
woman gets cosmetic surgery this is the
thing so they say I hate it but when you
see it they really can't tell the
difference and most of these two are
laughing names
a man especially a straight man getting
cosmetic surgery I just think
I think it's interesting that this
industry which started out being very
much a female thing is moving massively
towards that equality uh and I just
think some in some cases I think it's
quite sad because you're seeing younger
and younger yeah who are already
beautiful they're fit they're healthy
they don't need it you know and you see
it on the love Island and all that the
beautiful young women with lovely faces
and they're adding all sorts of stuff
that they don't need I think it's a
symptom of the problem rather than the
actual problem I think it's it's
generally it's it's something a lot
deeper on a societal level than just
trying to look perfect social media
pressure Kevin you're still a lot there
is you know no no but you can tell but
if you have something what would you do
What if I I don't need to do it I mean
if you had to if you had the screen what
you'd like to think what uh what do I
have that doesn't mean yeah
exactly you know obviously do you even
need to ask it's an elf on me
what about hair transplants
no you know if it goes It goes you know
I mean that's it yeah
great
well um as we've been discussing we are
going to meet Stephen uh the young man
who's addicted to enhancing his
appearance through surgery or is it one
slice too far that's coming up next
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
well the Quest for the perfect body is
on the rise across the UK I'm pretty
happy with mine but one leading cosmetic
doctor claimed that young people have
lost the plot by overdoing affordable
cosmetic surgery well Stephen Jarvis has
spent more than thirty thousand pounds
in the search for physical Perfection
Steven's first cosmetic procedure was
his teeth which cost a whopping 11
000 pounds they are very beautiful teeth
I have to say he has had a number of
other cosmetic procedures on his face
including Botox and fillers costing
around four thousand pounds now we're
not talking an old person here he's very
useful and years ago he used to weigh 19
and a half Stones that's about 125 kilos
it took drastic action and had a gastric
band costing six thousand pounds now
that worked pretty well and he lost
nearly eight stone and went right down
to 50 kg but he still wasn't satisfied
he then had all the excess skin removed
and no fewer than seven very serious
procedures in one Go including a Tommy
Tuck liposuction on his chest costing
ten thousand pounds and numerous other
things that are really too scary to
mention so this here is what Stephen
looked like before all his renovation
works and Stephen joins us now alongside
uh Jane DeVille Armand from the national
obesity Forum well Stephen thank you
very much for coming in
um you have an amazing physique now
thank you um but we looked at the
pictures of you before and I can't say
there was anything that much wrong with
them I dress very well why why did you
go down this such a drastic route so I
was diagnosed with diabetes and then I
was put on an array of medication from
trial drugs to normal everyday drugs
that diabetics can get with that my
weight was jumping from one side to the
other on the scale right so I couldn't
get to grips with it right so from that
my weight literally was going up up and
up then I would just stay at the what
you've got and that obviously made you
very unhappy yeah like I didn't like
what I saw because I was never that big
before so I was like why why should I
stay like this okay so you've got the
gastric band on and that tackled the
weight but left you with a load of extra
skin yeah and is that where it all
started in terms of right I need to get
rid of that and yes it's like what can I
take away and what can I do to look the
way I want to look and can you just
exercise and you know find ways of doing
that I'd had
um a lot of consultations I've been to
see like personal trainers and I've been
to see like surgeons and I was like
let's see what is best I've take both
opinions and even the personal trainers
you did your research two years worth of
research so that's your body yeah but
why have you done all this stuff to your
face you've got a lovely face really
young so when when you do lose weight
you do lose weight within your face and
obviously I'm too young now to do a
facelift so by doing fillers Botox and
other things aesthetically to my face
that replenishes and rejuvenates no skin
so so let's bring in uh um let's bring
in Jane here Jane a very good evening
thanks for being with us so you've heard
what um what Stephen has said what are
your thoughts I mean it's Steven's body
it's his choice he's got the money to do
it surely that's that's fine isn't it
uh well first of all can I just say I'm
from the British Obesity Society not the
national obesity foreign
um I think um in Stephen's case I think
because he's had
um gastric bands and obviously lots of
uh people who need to lose excessive
amounts of weight when they have a band
or a bypass they very often do feel very
unhappy with the skin that's left on
their body and I can absolutely
understand why anyone who's had
um massive weight loss will then decide
to have um their body
their skin removed because it is
unsightly isn't it Stephen it's it's you
know
it's very very unsightly people are very
unhappy however
um I have to say you look fantastic
thank you but I think I I think you know
um there are clinical reasons why people
need to have cosmetic surgery such as
gastric bands and gastric bypasses
people who've got you know um growth on
their face maybe or somebody who's got
something that's that needs removing and
they need to rebuild phases but I find
it really sad that young people like you
Stephen and like lots of young people
today
um feel unhappy with how they look
because actually it's always just
unhappiness because I'm happy like I say
like well I said God carve my face with
one set of chisels and threw them away
I'm just amending what he's made like
I'm not saying that I wasn't happy how I
looked my body I was unhappy with my
face I'm just I'm altering it to my my
judgment of perfection where will you
stop so you've already done all these
things you went you actually went to
Turkey for the most radical surgery yeah
um and you you paid for it all up front
or yep so I saved like over that two
years period I was saving just kept
putting money aside like I would do
extra work I work seven days a week and
how long were you in hospital for all
those procedures I was there high
narrowing and something yes I had inner
thigh tightening I had had chess lipo
chest sculpting chest tightening of the
skin full-time retuct abdomen repairs
this is dangerous right were you not
frightened no because I've done my
research I was totally happy with you've
done your research but how Jane um to
what extent is this uh is this increase
the product of pressure on social media
the various different platforms uh for
the perfect body
well I mean you know I look at social
media now and I'm not being rude or
cruel but you know everyone looks the
same to me everyone's got the same team
the same thing I can't yeah everyone
looks I can't tell the difference
between people anymore Stephen you know
no one looks like him come on Stephen
respond to that there isn't anyone else
that looks like me I'm I'm a mixed race
person of so many different ethnicities
like in my family yeah we look alike but
I've never seen another person that you
could say I look like very quickly tell
us what else you want to do you would
think this is the first product but no I
have heard you say you are thinking of
leg lengthening yeah I did look at that
I'd love to be taller like I'd love to
be six first that does involve breaking
your legs right yeah but then I won't be
able to work for quite a while so that's
off the cards okay never
yeah never for that hands I think you've
mentioned that before well yeah you can
you can replenish yourself apparently
you can have it if I can replenish it so
many more things to work on yeah but you
can have like when you lose weight like
that's what ages Jane you're shaking
your head what what are your thoughts
honestly I I think you've already
alluded to you know every single time we
go under a medical procedure you might
have done all your research I've been
nursing for 49 years and trust me uh
things go wrong they don't mean to go
wrong but you know and and it might be
the most amazing surgeon but things do
go wrong every time you go under an
anesthetic you put in your life at risk
well yeah definitely that's that is true
but there's that's why I will do my
research and if I was told by the
surgeon this is really not for you I'm
not just going to go and do it thank you
very much thank you Stephen well done
you're very brave I have to say that's
it and thank you Jane and whatever
you're up to make sure you keep it
uncensored a very good night
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you